please donate to give directly the
non-profit letting you send cash
directly to the world's poorest families
when you donate to give directly.org
Pacman a generous donor will match your
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
makes a perfect holiday gift help us
reach fifteen thousand dollars by the
end of the year using the link below
today we're going to start with two
different interviews it's a tale of two
interviews with liar Congressman elect
George Santos a republican in the first
interview we are going to see George
Santos interviewed by a woman named Skye
ostricher from the political
personalities with Sky program this
seems to be almost like a friend of his
in fact it seems maybe they do know each
other from watching the interview
friendliest interview in the world and
yet it still is a disaster based on the
continued lies that Santos tells later
we will look at now Fox News
correspondent or contributor Tulsi
gabbard interviewing George Santos and
you know what
the tools his credit she does a good job
of calling out his lies so let's jump
right into it as a reminder for context
this is George Santos who won a seat at
the U.S House of Representatives as a
republican he basically made up his
entire life's history he lied about his
work history he lied about his
educational history he lied about being
Jewish
um he said he's gay and it does appear
that that's actually that part is
actually true uh but he's in some cases
calling these merely embellishments in
other cases saying well I never really
committed a crime
uh and in other cases uh sort of
doubling down in fact on some of the
lies so this that you're going to see
this is an insult to journalism this is
one of the most absurd parodies of
Journalism that I've ever seen Sky
ostricher first question what made you
feel like you needed to lie about your
resume gets interesting quick what
caused you to even feel the need to
exaggerate who you are we'll start it
this way look
um I didn't outright lie
um about my work he did experience uh
actually I'm fairly well-rounded in the
financial markets and capital markets
I've been doing now whether you're
well-rounded or not you literally said
you worked at places you didn't work for
a very long time
um but I'll take you back to the
beginning So and I've worked as a
customer service agent for six seven
months of my life or so eight maybe if
in some at some point in 2011 2012 okay
uh and you know I'm not ashamed of it
Skye but the moment I put that on a
resume and I put it out there elitists
like the New York Times like to call
Blue Collar jobs like that odd jobs guys
you see what's going on here it's
because of the elitist woke New York
Times that wouldn't have taken his
customer service experience seriously
that he essentially had no choice but to
claim to work for Goldman Sachs or
wherever it was it's because of the woke
New York Times that he had to do it he
didn't really have a choice they forced
him into it because you know it just
doesn't fit their uh bourgeoisie style
lifestyle right so that bougie left
Media made me have to lie about my
experience it's it's those expectations
and those negative connotations from
elitist organizations such as the New
York Times that lead people like me who
I've I'm very comfortable in saying I
come from poverty I I come from a family
of absolute nothing and I've worked
really hard to get where I am today
um and the reality is is yes I I omitted
like past employment history that was
irrelevant to the role although one can
argue customer service is pretty
important but he also made up employment
history that didn't exist because of
Congress but I guess they just don't see
it that way
um and and you know for for poor use of
words maybe and yeah this guy made it up
whole cloth okay and he's essentially
saying they made me do it they're they
just have these X expectations it's
everybody else's fault that I uh that I
had to make it up which I kind of didn't
then he explains why he was married to a
woman now this I actually don't find
this to really be a super interesting
part of the story because
because of social pressures and stigma
and a lot of different reasons it's not
that rare that gay men at some point
have relationships with women or might
even be married to women it's it is
interesting to hear them explain it
though now the one thing I will say is
I'm sorry for having had a life for
having had a complicated life oh maybe I
married yeah I did marry young and I
married a young woman at the time and we
we pretty much were in love and then we
weren't because that's why I decided
after a long time like many who don't to
come out and say I'm gay and I'm not
going to lead you along and this is
toxic and this relationship isn't going
to work and I set myself free and I set
her free I think this is completely fine
I don't think this is a big deal
whatsoever then they go into what about
your constituents what are your
constituents thinking about all of this
dishonesty so George how do you think
your constituents are feeling right now
um I I can't answer that because I don't
know
um I have people who have reached out to
me and given me the utmost support I
have people who have reached out to me
frustrated with the reports and wanting
to know more and I have been giving the
same explanation to people one off for
the last couple of days I was silent to
the media because I don't dance to the
tune of the New York Times right
whichever MSNBC or whoever I get to the
tunes of my constituents so I've been
very heavily intensively on the phone
talking to them calling them making sure
people he's been have by the way this
guy just makes up words heavily
incentively yesterday he made up the
word ingrangiate and the phrase uh the
the knit and gritty as opposed to the
nitty-gritty he's constantly making up
words it's sort of like an interesting
aside who volunteered and it's been an
overwhelming response of George we
elected you to get a job done we didn't
care what your resume looked like quite
frankly right if they didn't care then
why did Eli of course is the question
well because the New York Times made him
one question has been will he resign
increasing pressure on him to resign
this interview was from uh two days ago
at this point point he makes it very
clear he's not going to resign however
maybe he will because things have
changed since get stuff done I will be
an effective member of Congress I will
be a diligent member of Congress and I
will be able to deliver results for
congress for the people of New York
state district because
I'm not going to allow this to deter me
from doing that right so making it clear
he's not going to resign however the
pressure continues mounting and maybe he
will end up resigning now here was an
interesting question and I'll you'll
find out why it's interesting very
quickly
he has made claims about property
ownership in this interview he's asked
by Sky ostricher playing the role of a
of an interviewer in this video about
the property stuff take a listen to what
he says
okay I mean that's a good attitude to
have I have a few other questions that
maybe we can address really quick about
property that you own George do you own
property do you not so George Santos uh
me personally I've never claimed to own
property myself I have never claimed to
own property myself okay that's pretty
clear no I do not own property I've I've
never purchased property under my name
I've got your family property I think
Emily has property and I'm able to use
of their property and I help them out
with uh you know keeping the books and
stuff like that but that's a family
affair okay so no property doesn't have
property never claim to own property
here he is saying he sold the property
uh okay let's see if I've got this lined
up right let's take a listen
you know it's funny I two years ago I
sold a property I had on 28th Avenue I
sold a property I had not I helped my
family sell a property of theirs I sold
a property I had like definitely you
know it's funny I two years ago I sold a
prop
I can go all the way down by the water
right just go straight right because the
shelter went up on 20th Avenue and and
it was very controversial and and I sold
the property there but what I can tell
you is that that area should have never
been built on that is a swamp that used
to be the flushing airport and the swamp
took over it and then they insisted in
building up a an academy there
you know it's a beautiful building I
think it's a gorgeous project yeah I've
never claimed to own a property oh I
sold a property I had because I didn't
like the fact that a shelter went up
doesn't really sound like you're saying
it's a family property does it so just
it's lie on top of lie on top of lie
then we get to the issue of um his false
claims that he's Jewish uh Okay let's
listen to that okay
and the controversy about your ancestors
in the Holocaust how did that how did
that become such a story in these
different Jewish Publications whether
they were in the Holocaust or they
weren't in the Holocaust and do I wish
you a happy Hanukkah or Merry Christmas
so as I've said many times and I think
you've heard me say this I always joke
I'm Catholic but I'm also Jewish
guys can't you tell he's Jewish
uh and I've made that joke because
growing up I grew up fully aware that my
grandparents were Jewish came from from
a Jewish family and they were refugees
to Brazil and that was always the story
I grew up with and I've always known it
very well and I've told it the way it
was told to me now if if It just strikes
me so odd that people are rushing to dis
inherit me from being Jewish or for even
allowing to he's there's no evidence
that those stories are true care for
Israel and Judaism in a time and and
guys he likes Israel why can't we just
call him Jewish I mean if it after after
all that why can't we just allow him to
do it now of course Rolling Stone report
George Santos who said he never claimed
to be Jewish once called himself a quote
proud American Jew
proud American Jew I never claimed to be
Jewish no I never claimed that
um okay and then one more video here
what does uh George say to people who
now worry they won't be able to trust
him
are there people I'm sure there are what
do you say to them that are gonna hold
this against you and say that they can't
trust you because of these exaggerations
that you've made exaggeration so you
were able to trust
um
worse people they were able to trust
Andrew Cuomo who sexually harassed women
through his argument is they've trusted
worse people than me
throughout his entire career they were
able to trust his James who harbored a
sexual predator as her Chief of Staff
right they were able to trust a Litany
of politicians in this country who have
literally sold this country out look at
the president of the United States so
guess what I will make them Trust Me by
delivering results I'm not here for
self-empowerment self and Grandeur I'm
just here to get stuff done because I
want to leave a country better off to
the next yeah so I I guess you should
trust him because worse people have held
office a humiliating attempt and an
interview by Sky ostricher and just lies
upon lies the dishonesty is just seeping
through this guy's every poor and
orifice of his body
um horrifying a horrible liar and
fortunately Tulsi gabbard actually took
him to task all right listen I have
absolutely no problem criticizing
someone I normally praise or praising
someone I normally criticize broken
clocks can sometimes be right
functioning clocks sometimes run out of
battery and give you the wrong time of
day so the point is we evaluate each
thing individually and last night Tulsi
gabbard former Democrat Tulsi gabbard no
longer a Democrat who Now supported like
Herschel Walker and looked the worst of
the worst Carrie Lake Etc in 2022
she filled in for Fox News propaganda's
Tucker Carlson last night and she
interviewed habitual liar
republican-elect George Santos and I
have to tell you she really did a pretty
damn good job and I my earpiece is
flying out and I want to be able to hear
this so let me tuck it back in uh neatly
there
she actually does a good job of calling
it what it is take a listen to Tulsi and
George Santos the results that are
called into question when you tell
blatant and he increasingly gets
flustered which is great embellishments
and this is this is I think one of the
biggest concerns congressmen elect is
that you don't really seem to be taking
this seriously you've apologized you
said you've made mistakes but you've
outright lie a lie is not an
embellishment on a resume you said you
worked at Goldman Sachs and Citigroup
but they've said we've got no record of
this guy working for us you said you've
gone to and graduated from these
universities but they've said well we've
got no record of that these are blatant
lies and it calls into question how your
constituents and the American people can
believe anything that you may say when
you are standing on the floor of the
House of Representatives now this is a
question
supposedly fighting for them that's the
real issue here
well look I and I I agree with what
you're saying and as I stated and I
continue
we can debate my my resume and how I
work you really it's not really for
debate though with firms such as is it
debatable or is it just false
yes
debatable I no no it's not false at all
it's it's debatable like it's totally
false I want to explain to you what you
can do in private equity in in capital
intro via servicing limited partners and
general partners and we can have this
discussion that's going to go way above
the American people's head yeah it would
be too complicated for the American
people for me to explain why it's not
really a lie for me to say I worked for
Goldman when I didn't because I worked
for a company that had Goldman as a
client and Well why'd you put Goldman on
your resume then it's not what I
campaigned on I campaigned on delivering
results for the American people by
lowering inflation I can sit down and if
you want to have that discussion I'd be
glad to Tulsi to explain that to you and
make sure that we we settled the score
that this is not about settling scores
and I think you just you just kind of
highlighted I think my concern the
concern that people at home have you're
saying that this discussion will go way
above the heads of the American people
basically insulting their intelligence
so not only are you now that's not what
I'm saying that you've told that's
exactly what he's saying but but you're
saying that you can't it's not when it's
in a way that your constituents would
actually be able to I can explain it in
a way to give me the time I can easily
give the if you give me the time I can
easily explain it for you as as in when
investors are looking for Capital and
I'm sitting there doing due diligence on
the on the appetite and what they're
looking at if this is all to explain why
he claimed to work at Goldman Sachs when
he did not when tool sees not buying
your lies you know you're digging pretty
deep here here's another clip from this
interview and again to tulsi's credit
she confronted him and he got
increasingly flustered because he should
because he's lying
so I can deliver for the American people
the thing is Congressman elect uh
integrity means yes carrying yourself
with honor but it means it means telling
the truth being a person of integrity
and if I were one of those in New York's
Third District right now now that the
election is over and I'm finding out all
of these lies that you've told not just
one little lie or one little
embellishment these are blatant lies my
question is do you have no shame do you
have no shame in the people who are now
you are asking to trust you to go and be
their voice for them their families and
their kids in Washington
Tulsi I can say the same thing about the
Democrats and and the party look at your
body but don't the Democrats have shame
but we're not talking about them we're
talking about you claiming that you were
Jewish when you weren't lying to the
American people for 40 years he's the
president of the United States Democrats
but Biden once lied who resoundly
support him do they have no shame
because look this is made this very this
is not this is not about the Democratic
party though this is about your
relationship frankly with the people
who've entrusted you to go and and fight
for them and I think one of the
questions that that really probably by
the way asking whether he has shame as
she sits in Tucker Carlson's chair is
pretty rich but this is not about Tulsi
it's home to a lot of people is is are
you Jewish we've got a letter that your
campaign sent out earlier this year
which reads as follows as a proud
American Jew I've been to Israel
numerous times for educational business
and leisurely trips you said there in
that letter that you are quote proud
American Jew how do you how do you
explain that
my Heritage is Jewish I've always
identified as Jewish I was raised a
practice he just said in the other
interview I played for you that he has
always identified as Catholic but here
he says I've always identified as Jewish
in Catholic I think I've gone through
this even I've not not being raised to
practicing Jew I've always joked with
friends and circles even with in the
campaign I'd say guys I'm Jewish
remember I was raised Catholic so look I
understand everybody man Tulsi is just
not buying it so good job by Tulsi I
have no problem praising her even though
I think most of her contributions to
American politics are quite negative uh
and Santos is just so dishonest in the
earlier interview he says no no no
listen I've always said I'm Catholic
here he says no no no no I've always
identified as Jewish but I'm also kind
of Catholic and this and that and I'm
Jewish and there's a hyphen guys there's
a hyphen
The Hyphen makes all the difference in
the world this guy should resign
I hope that Republicans say you can't
stay dude you gotta go we will follow it
and let you know make sure you were
subscribed to the YouTube channel over 3
million different people watched Clips
in November and didn't subscribe if we
can just get a fraction of those folks
to hit the Subscribe button on YouTube
will be at 2 million subscribers before
you know it quick break and we'll be
right back
over this holiday season please remember
how many families around the world are
living in extreme poverty our partner
give directly is the non-profit letting
you send cash directly to the world's
poorest households help the David
packman show reach our goal of fifteen
thousand dollars by the end of the year
at give directly.org Pacman a generous
give directly donor will match all
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
to help us hit that goal so your
donation can have double the impact
giving in someone's name is a great last
minute holiday gift when organizations
give cash to families like this about 90
cents on the dollar get to the recipient
versus sometimes as little as 50 cents
on the dollar in terms of relative
impact with many other programs that's
why I reached out to give directly about
doing this with us give directly is how
you know every dollar you donate is
going to good use giving even a few
dollars can have a massive impact for
someone living on a dollar or two a day
help us reach fifteen thousand dollars
by December Thirty One and your donation
will be doubled go to give directly.org
Pacman the link is down below the David
packman show is an audience supported
podcast YouTube Channel radio show and
television program I encourage you to
sign up at joinpakman.com it's a very
very small and inexpensive way to get
some great perks and support the work
that we do every day we do an extra show
for our members called the bonus show we
also offer commercial free audio and
video streams of the show and membership
includes invitations to the members only
Town Halls the next of which will be
scheduled very very soon sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now that's 2-4
Starts Now for a sizable discount off of
the cost of a membership we should
really find a way to help in cells those
who are involuntarily celibate and we
should do it in a way that does not
include forcing women to have sex with
them which has actually been suggested
by some David what on Earth are you
talking about so let's back it up in
cell is short for involuntarily celibate
and it's more than just being
involuntarily celibate meaning you'd
like to be sexually active but you're
unable to find a partner it also has a
sort of entire subculture
and unfortunately there have been
elements of incel that have been
interwoven with mass Shooters in some
cases which have not uh gone unnoticed
and more broadly there is a concern and
I believe it is a warranted concern that
in general it's not just mass shootings
there is broader anti-social rather than
pro-social behavior that emanates from
this group that is in many cases
disaffected in many cases depressed
using that as a colloquial term not
necessarily clinical depression but just
dissatisfied and sad about the status of
their lives Etc and I believe we need to
find a way to help these folks including
to find healthier role models than the
people that they often end up worshiping
folks like Jordan Peterson and Andrew
Tate so we have to consider the
circumstances first you've got a group
that among other
grievances with Society they're upset
they can't find a romantic partner
there's loneliness
there's isolation the suffering of
rejection in many cases and the reason
that it would be important to find a
very specific way to help this group of
people is not just that if we can
improve someone's life it's a great
thing to do but there's this
self-fulfilling prophecy that happens
often within the incel community where
it's bad for society not to help them
the very isolation and rejection Etc
that they suffer leads them to the path
where they find negative Role Models
like Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tate and
then they end up blaming everyone else
for their misery instead of maybe
looking more at themselves and changing
themselves and they end up adopting some
of the worst traits of the people that
they follow
it's not just Jordan Peterson and Andrew
Tate there's all sorts of like Charisma
coaches and pickup artists and all this
different stuff and it makes them even
less desirable to the very people they
are trying to appeal to so we've got to
figure out how to do something in cells
are often portrayed in a negative light
in society as well and we know of
individuals within the incel community
that have embraced hateful ideologies
sometimes the anger at the world and for
heterosexual in cells the anger at the
women that won't give them the time of
day
grows into a hateful ideology that
includes other groups of people as well
and then sometimes it even leads to
Violent real world actions so number one
it's important to understand that for
the vast majority of in cells that's not
actually the path they're not they're
not going to become violent that's not
what we're talking about they're just
folks struggling with isolation
sometimes it's self-esteem difficulty
forming romantic and sexual
relationships we should give them
compassion and support rather than
judging and condemning them as so many
people do on the internet so the
question is how can Society help in
cells what can actually be done
it's all pretty I don't want to say milk
toast stuff but what I mean is nothing's
going to be particularly titillating I
think we've all really kind of know what
needs to be done the resources and
support need to be there for people who
are struggling with either body image or
self-esteem issues that become this
feedback loop because of their
difficulty finding a partner
we we have to establish systems of
support for them that aren't belittling
or condescending we should encourage
people to seek out therapy or counseling
to try to work through the issues that
are underlying what often is a pretty
severe social anxiety either primary or
as a result of their lack of success
forming these relationships lack of
self-confidence sometimes there's past
traumas or a particularly acute event
where they were rejected by someone
which now has a subsequent feedback loop
and becomes a self-filling prophecy all
of that stuff may need to sort of be
worked through and so you've got to
offer education you have to think about
what resources can be established to
really think about how how do you
navigate dating how do you navigate
relationships how can you relate to
whoever it is that you consider to be in
your dating pool based on you know your
sexual orientation communication skills
understanding boundaries in some cases
helping people connect with not only
others like them
struggling with the same thing but also
with those that they would like to be
building relationships with and it could
be online it could be in person we're
not really doing this and it sort of
does fall under the umbrella of we need
to fund mental health the right loves to
say
this problem is mental health that
problem is mental health anything Gunner
violence related is definitely mental
health and then given the opportunity
they often opt not to properly fund
dealing with the mental health
components so we need to do that here
and again it's I know that it's very
popular to kind of just like make fun of
in cells or whatever you know it's just
kind of like ridicule it or see it as
not really a serious problem it's it's a
real serious problem in society because
it is a perpetuating mechanism a
feedback loop for anti-social behavior
that sometimes sometimes grows into
actual violent Acts
send me your thoughts about as
specifically as possible
what Canon should be done to support
these folks to hopefully allow them to
improve their lives
Fox News and their medical team is
demanding that before uh miners are
allowed to Avail themselves of any
gender affirming care there should be
steps that have to be taken therapy for
example blood tests physical exams and
of course all these things are already
happening I'm going to show you these
clips this is this is pretty wild stuff
so Fox News had this panel with Dr Mark
Siegel and some other people and they
were talking about uh trans kids and
this is a very hot button issue right
now it really agitates the right it's
one of the top issues they like talking
about
here is one doctor saying what should be
required take a listen I completely
agree with Dr Siegel I mean she is not
the god of science science you know
medicine they call it a practice because
this is Dr Jeanette neshawat Fox News
contributor constantly evolving we need
to change our guidelines and our
protocols as we progress as we learn
more information but gender dysphoria
this is a very serious and sensitive
issue a very serious topic because it
has a very high suicide rate very high
suicidal ideation rate of up to 42
percent of those who struggle with their
identity think about suicide because of
the stress that that it has on them and
even their families so I don't think
it's right for Rachel Levine to impose
it seems her personal views on all of us
instead you know we know that some
people will benefit from uh you know
transitioning and gender affirming care
but we want to do it the right way and
that starts off with taking a history
and a physical maybe doing blood work
getting counseling and therapy not
rushing to hormones and irreversible
surgeries that might have long-term
consequences or irreversible so she has
some ideas of things that should happen
before surgeries take place Let's watch
One More clip and then we'll talk about
this it's about approximately two-thirds
you know it's just it's Dr Siegler you
mentioned it when
should these things be approached with
the people with the individuals who are
experiencing gender dysphoria there
there's got to be an age that is too
young right well for sure puberty is too
young to be talking about transition and
that's where all the debating is going
on and the mental health issues are
really important because 70 or more of
those that have gender dysphoria have
major mental health issues going on
simultaneously we can't sweep that under
the rug we have to what's the downside
of counseling yeah what's the downside
of seeing a therapist and working
through what you're feeling okay so
listen
they have ideas about what should take
place before minors are allowed to do
certain things or even maybe they're
talking about adults here it's not
totally clear but they definitely seem
concerned about minors that's going on
the requirements vary to some degree
state by state but generally speaking to
to even get going down this path there
is a protocol and it does start with the
physical exam and the initial
conversation oftentimes there is some
blood testing that's done and at a
certain point a diagnosis is established
of gender dysphoria now some of these
folks don't believe that gender
dysphoria is a real thing but others say
well you should actually have to be
diagnosed after going through an initial
okay well so for those people in that
latter group
you get the diagnosis after an
evaluation often it includes a mental
health professional like a psychologist
or a psychiatrist making that diagnosis
to even be able to enter this entire
path that's a requirement in just about
every state or requirement part of the
protocol and they're talking about
protocol for the most part
um evidence of informed consent is
required when you're talking about
minors minors may be required to show
that they really understand the risks
benefits implications and possible
complications of whatever it is that
they're agreeing with their doctor that
they want to do and in some cases this
also requires the informed consent of
the parent or Guardian depends on the
state there's controversial aspects to
that but that's part of the protocol
already again they're saying they want
this stuff this is already part of the
protocol
um three in order to move to the surgery
component you often need evidence of
long-term hormone therapy as well as uh
therapy uh talk their Psychotherapy to
talk about and explore how that is going
and whether the surgery is actually the
not logical Next Step there are states
that require minors to have been taking
hormones for a certain amount of time
before they're even eligible for surgery
and this is to make sure the family the
individuals everybody knows how does
this work to some degree it's really the
right thing for me Etc and then at the
tail end of all of this almost always a
letter from a mental health professional
who has been involved in this often from
the get-go uh saying here are all the
things we've done I believe that surgery
is appropriate and that this individual
is well suited and predisposed to
surgery sometimes that Psychotherapy
period goes on for a period of time as
well again depending on the state
that's what they say we listen we just
can't go around doing this stuff
willy-nilly I mean what's wrong with
therapy and a physical exam and getting
the diagnosis that's that's the protocol
that's the protocol I have still not
found and I am more than willing to
review evidence if anybody has it for me
I have not found any place you can just
kind of show up and say uh I think I'd
like surgery oh have you been diagnosed
with gender dysphoria have you uh done
hormone therapy have you met with no I
just want sure yeah next week come in
and we'll do the therapy I've just not
heard of that anywhere in the United
States if it exists
I want to know more about it let me know
but I was able to find no evidence of it
so I guess the good news is the protocol
that fox doctors want to see
already is in place the next step is
getting them to mention that rather than
saying five-year-olds are getting their
breasts cut off
five-year-olds have breasts well no but
they're still doing come on guys come on
we'll have these clips on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman's
show on Instagram
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
our friend Congressman Jamie Raskin
who's been a guest on this program says
that Donald Trump will likely end his
life Behind Bars this I have to see
because I have a very very difficult
time believing that Newsweek reports
Trump likely to be indicted will end
life quote Behind Bars Congressman says
former president Donald Trump will
likely be indicted and spend the rest of
his life Behind Bars representative
Jamie Raskin said on Saturday Raskin is
a Maryland Democrat and served on the
house select committee investigating the
capital riots the panel spent months
probing Trump's role in the Insurrection
okay Raskin reflected about the
significance of the report issued by the
committee during an appearance on Yahoo
news's skullduggery podcast Saturday the
Democratic lawmaker said he quote would
be really would be surprised if attorney
general Merritt Garland did not indict
Trump for his alleged role in the riot
adding that it's so clear that the
president intended to interfere with the
election certification Raskin went on to
say I do think it's very very important
that we establish that it's not just
foot soldiers but kingpins who are
prosecuted and that it's just wrong to
send hundreds of foot soldiers to jail
and leave the very clear Kingpin
unprosecuted he added that Trump could
spend the rest of his life in prison if
he's convicted on January 6 charges
there's just deep culpability from the
very beginning in Don everything that
Donald Trump did I'm very serious about
him facing the consequences and paying
for the cost of his action he could
spend the remaining days of his
misanthropic Life Behind Bars presumably
with Secret Service agents I would love
for Jamie Raskin to be correct here I
really would the blatant criminality and
flouting of the law by Donald Trump is
absolutely stunning and appalling and we
hope that the safeguards we have in
place are actually robust and strong
enough that they can hold someone like
Donald Trump accountable I would love
for Jamie Raskin to be right that that
accountability is going to be prison
time I don't think that it is and again
it goes through let's think through the
steps first step is Donald Trump has to
be indicted hasn't happened yet but
maybe it will great Trump gets indicted
next step is does it even go to trial or
is Trump as a former president who will
have the best of the best legal advice
going to strike a deal and make a deal
either where he doesn't have to admit to
any guilt but he pays fines or he um has
to plead guilty to something minor and
the consequence of jail time prison time
is not even on the table if you get
beyond that and you say okay he's gonna
have to go to trial and it's going to
include the possibility of a prison
sentence
how do you get a jury to fairly evaluate
a former president's actions I don't
know who you can find that wouldn't
bring a strong preconceived notion and
preconceived opinion about Trump's guilt
or Renaissance and by the way as I've
said before if you can find people who
really have no opinion I would wonder
whether where they've been for the last
six years and whether these are even
really the people competent enough to
serve on a jury although it's a jury of
your peers I understand everybody gets
to serve so how do you even put a jury
together
if you then get a guilty verdict that
sticks that doesn't get appealed there
may not necessarily be prison time and
if there is a guilty verdict and if
there is prison time
and Trump gets sentenced
older wealthy folks close to 80 years
old with prison sentences use every
possibility available to them every
health issue that they have and argue
for house arrest instead of actual
prison so I believe that if everything
went perfectly indictment serious
charges conviction sentencing that even
includes prison time
I think you get a suspended sentence or
at the very very worst for Trump you get
home confinement so I know he's Mr
Perfect Health six three two thirty nine
healthiest president ever I assure you
that will be a very different story
painted about his health if all of a
sudden prison is on the table and I
would bet anything
that Trump doesn't see a day in a jail
or prison cell if you disagree with me I
want to hear from you I just don't see
it Donald Trump looks scared as hell in
a deranged new video attacking the
recent report from the January 6 Trump
Riot committee we're going to look at
the clip this guy seems nervous this guy
seems scared even though I don't believe
he will see even a single day inside of
a prison cell no matter what happens he
doesn't want to be the indicted
president he doesn't want to have the
next four years of his life who knows
how many years he has left tied up
dealing with a criminal trial look at
Trump check this out
we wanted security we wanted safety
there was no Insurrection and there
wasn't going to be an Insurrection it
was made up by these sick people I've
never seen Trump look like this behave
like this talk like this Nancy Pelosi
and the D.C mayor refused if they'd
listen to me my recommendation none of
this would have happened now remember
we've learned since first Trump kept
saying I wanted 10 to 20 000 troops to
protect the capital and Nancy Pelosi
turned him down and what we realized was
Nancy Pelosi didn't turn anything down
Trump didn't request 10 to 20 000 troops
to protect the capital it's actually
even sicker we've now learned Trump
wanted 10 000 troops to protect him on
January 6th him not to protect the
capital to protect him it's insane that
that's actually the truth of the matter
and you wouldn't have heard about
January 6th as we know it they covered
up multiple tweets and they covered up
video which were censored by Twitter and
the FBI in which I called for Law and
Order and for no violence this this
should be an exhibit at whatever trial
is forthcoming and then they pushed and
observed and discredited story where I
supposedly lunch for the steering wheel
in an attempt to commandeer a
presidential limousine think of it I
lunged for a steering wheel and they
believed that story nobody believes that
story the committee jump Cuts doing a
lot of work here I can only imagine what
the experience of watching Trump film
this was like barely even discussed the
catastrophic security failures at the
Capitol and they didn't discuss the
other thing the reason that everybody
went there the election which was a
corrupt disaster they did not discuss
why the doors were flung wide open for
people to walk right in and they didn't
discuss the role of federal informants
most importantly the unselect committee
did not produce a single shred of
evidence that I in any way intended or
wanted violence at our Capital the
evidence does not exist because the
claim is baseless and a monstrous lie
they know it it's just like the
russia-russia Russia hoax this is
absolutely no different it's
misinformation the only thing they're
good at cheating in elections
misinformation remember there was no
cheating in the election by democrats
the events of January 6 were not an
Insurrection they were a protest that
tragically got out of control and which
the left has been weaponizing ever since
to censor spion and persecute American
citizens the entire phony hoax is about
taking away your speech taking away your
vote and taking away your freedom these
are sick people these are marxists and
they're very dangerous and very big now
as you know there would really be no
connection between Marxism and any of
the things that Donald Trump is talking
about that is unhinged and understand
that with the jump Cuts where it's like
Trump's in a different part of the
screen every time they cut it and we
know why this happens because we've seen
the uncensored video of Trump trying to
record these things he can barely speak
and it's really just a triggering
experience for him I can only imagine
that given that this was the best video
they could put together
that this guy was just exploding behind
the scenes about this thing he seemed
scared he seems terrified he doesn't
want to be the indicted president which
he may be I don't know what the big 2023
story is going to be but if I were a
betting man at this point I might be
saying it's the Trump indictment we will
see we will take a break and be back
right after this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well this
is just unbelievable except of course
it's not Mark Meadows who served as
Donald Trump's Chief of Staff up until
the end of Donald Trump's presidential
term has now been accused of Burning
official documents in his office yes a
fire in his office it is stunning what
we continue to learn about what took
place Politico reports Meadows burned
papers after meeting with Scott Perry
January 6th panel was told then white
house chief of staff Mark Meadows burned
papers in his office after meeting with
a house Republican who was working to
challenge the 2020 election according to
testimony that the January 6 committee
heard from Cassidy Hutchinson who worked
under Meadows when he was Trump's Chief
of Staff The Meadows Perry meeting came
in the weeks after election day as Trump
and his allies searched for ways to
reverse the election results it's
unclear whether Hutchinson told the
committee which specific papers were
burnt and if Federal records laws
required the materials preservation
Meadow's destruction of papers is a key
Focus for the select committee and the
person familiar with the testimony said
investigators pressed Hutchinson for
details about the issue for more than 90
minutes for more than 90 minutes another
report
from the hill former Trump White House
aide Cassidy Hutchinson indicated Mark
Meadows burned documents in his
fireplace roughly a dozen times in the
final weeks of the administration
Hutchinson became a star witness in the
panel's public hearings told the
committee on May 17 she saw Meadows
burned documents once they turned his
office fireplace uh
once they turned I guess it's supposed
to say turned his fireplace on in
December of 2020. the presidential
record Act only asks that you keep the
original copy of a document so yes
Hutchinson asked said when asked if she
saw Meadows use the fireplace to burn
documents however I don't know if they
were the first or original copies of
anything it's entirely possible he had
put things in his fireplace he would
have put into a burn bag that were
duplicates or that were there was an
electronic copy of I want to say once or
twice a week I can't recall I can recall
specific times he did it maybe a dozen
maybe just over a dozen but this was
over a period December through
mid-January which is when we started
lighting the fireplace think of what was
going on at this White House Trump's
flushing documents down the toilet
um Meadows is burning documents in a
fireplace totally normal presidential
office stuff as a general rule
functioning democracies don't burn
official documents in a fireplace
functioning democracies don't flush
official documents down a toilet and
functioning democracies don't elect
elect mob boss types to run countries
now we have seen mob boss types run a
number of different countries and we
know it doesn't typically go
particularly well so the critical
question here of course is were these
Originals that were supposed to be
maintained as part of the presidential
records act were these duplicates of
some kind are there electronic records
we just don't know at this time what we
do know is if they're Originals under
federal law it is a crime to destroy
alter mutilate conceal cover-up falsify
or make a false entry in any record
document or tangible object with the
intent to impede obstruct or influence a
federal investigation or any matter
within the jurisdiction of any
department or agency of the United
States that's a very long rule or a very
long law what it means is any alteration
or destruction of a document
with the intent of getting in the way or
preventing a future investigation making
a future investigation difficult is a
crime the offense is punishable by a
fine
and imprisonment and or imprisonment up
to 20 years in addition to that the
federal records laws and regulations
require that federal agencies properly
create manage and preserve records
including those related to the White
House Nara the National Archives and
Records Administration an often
mentioned organization in the context of
the Trump Administration oversees all of
that and can take disciplinary action
against federal employees do I expect
Meadows to go down for this
I really don't this is more about the
habitual ease with which these people
regularly violated sometimes the law
sometimes convention and often protocol
and we're really going to get a test of
whether our legal system and rules and
regulations and checks and balances are
actually strong enough to create or
generate or resulting consequences for
the so many different people that
participated in the wrongdoing we'll
find out
Donald Trump's tax returns are going
public on Friday
it's finally happening we already know
much of what is in those tax returns
thanks to the report issued by the
January 6 committee but we're getting
them the tax returns are going to be
released Friday and it's going to be
wild NBC news reporting Trump tax
returns to be released to the public on
Friday
the Ways and Means Committee voted last
week to make six years of Trump's tax
returns public
um this was a party line vote initially
the plan was to release the documents as
early as last Wednesday
the disclosure was delayed due to having
to redact personal information like
Social Security numbers the assortment
of six years of Trump's personal tax
returns and some of his business returns
are expected to be placed into the
Congressional Record Friday
the clock is ticking for the committee
which will turn over control to
Republicans when the new Congress is
sworn in next week
another report from Reuters former
Republican president Donald Trump's
redacted tax returns will be made public
on Friday the documents to be released
Friday are expected to include Trump's
tax returns between 2015 and 2021 the
years he ran for and served as president
a spokesperson for Trump declined to
comment Trump was the first presidential
candidate in decades not to release his
tax returns during either of his
campaigns for president
so beyond the Trump aspects of this what
are we going to learn from the Trump
aspects okay we've gone over it so many
times he's not as rich as he claims to
be he has sketchy debts that raise
questions about being compromised in
National Security he uses this uh some
would call it fraudulent technique of
inflating the value of assets when he
wants to use the asset as collateral for
a loan but diminishing the value of an
asset when it's for the purposes of
figuring out how much attacks he's going
to owe on that answer oh there's the
Trump aspect to it we already learned
most of those things are true from the
summary the house released and we will
get I believe beyond a shadow of a doubt
confirmation from the tax returns
themselves beyond that there are banks
that will maybe end up under pressure
after these tax returns are released to
know from people wanting to know from
those Banks why did you keep loaning
this guy money
when his finances were clearly bad how
did you accept this valuation for a
building that was serving as collateral
when it so clearly was not the value of
the building so I believe there's going
to be attention on Banks and whether the
banks were sort of like look the other
way or whether the banks were complicit
in what some would call a fraud
um we are also going to see potentially
the argument made that you know
something is partisan and biased here
because there has never been this much
attention about any president's tax
returns the right is going to say you
know this is all a politically trumped
up witch-hunt way to go after Donald
Trump because you've never seen so many
people waiting for the tax returns of
another president well no other
president
refuse to release their tax returns and
then worked for six years to prevent
their release that's why there's a
spotlight on this
and they will claim the problem is that
people are eager to see the tax returns
now the reason we're even in this
situation is because Trump did something
nobody else has done
which is to say I'm just not going to
release them now he did say I will
release them once they're no longer
being audited but they weren't being
audited and you all know the lies but
the point here is what's unique isn't
that the tax returns are coming out it's
that they had to come out via this means
because Trump refused to otherwise
provide them so don't fall for that when
we certainly hear from Republicans you
know this is political partisanship
because Democrats are excited about the
tax returns no it's Trump who did the
thing nobody else has done we have a
voicemail number and that number is
2192 David P I mentioned Jewish
Christmas which is of course you get
Chinese or Indian food or really any
place that's open right it just tends to
be Asian restaurants and there's a
caller who is not thrilled with the
Indian food component of it take a
listen to this David it's Allen from
Jersey and watching the show today and
you're saying that the Jewish Christmas
is Chinese or Indian food correct I'm
like do you not understand the meaning
of the season the Christmas spirit how
could you
it's just like Jesus died for our sins
David and this is the day we celebrate
his birth not by Indian food I mean
that's the most ridiculous thing I've
ever heard so everyone knows it's
Chinese food and a movie there's a
Chinese food and a movie never Indian
food I don't know you can do Indian food
the rest of the year but this day Jesus
died so we could have the day off for
our movie and Chinese food okay and
specifically it has to be like maybe
Avatar too okay and we're now getting a
little bit too detailed so this is a
joke I don't think that guy's really mad
that I had Indian food on Christmas but
yes there's a long tradition there's in
fact a lot of interesting
um uh sort of like articles and Research
into this how did it end up that Jewish
folks get Asian food on Christmas and of
course the answer is relatively simple
Christmas is really boring if you're
Jewish I remember from when I was a kid
now it's less boring because no matter
what day it is I'm just chasing around a
baby but that that's a different story
but historically it's a very boring day
um and you order from the restaurants
that are open and uh typically those are
Asian restaurants of different kinds I
believe Indian food is just as
acceptable as Chinese food on Christmas
if you disagree with me you can let me
know we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
well we'll see if any money is made
today on today's bonus show we are going
to talk about the Supreme Court saying
the trump-era Border restrictions under
title 42 will remain in effect while
legal challenges play out very
controversial very hypocritical much of
what's gone on with title 42 we will
talk about it a bill forcing the feds to
fix prison cameras has been signed into
law prison cameras are actually a big
topic and I recently actually read a
book
um about prisons and we're going to talk
about prison cameras there's actually
quite a connection to police body
cameras as well there which we will
discuss and then lastly it has been
revealed that Donald Trump didn't
realize that the White House schedule
was a public document until there were
only weeks left of his presidency he
then realized wait a second what I'm
doing daily gets published and at that
point he asked for a much uh more
generic version to be published and
that's when you might remember in the
last few weeks of Trump's presidency his
schedule started to say things like the
president will have many meetings with
various people and work for the American
people
and we wondered that's really weird why
are they doing that it's clearly that
Trump isn't working
um he only learned then
that the president's official schedule
is a public document which is just
mind-blowing all of those stories and
more today on the bonus show when
producer Pat joins me remember get the
free white paper on how to argue
politics with people without burning the
bridge of the relationship with them
there's a free guide it's free it's
really free I'm not selling you anything
you can find it at davidpackman.com
slash guide davidpackman.com
slash guide it's free we'll see you on
the bonus show and back here tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors please donate to
give directly the non-profit letting you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest families when you donate to give
directly.org Pacman a generous donor
will match your donations up to fifteen
thousand dollars makes a perfect holiday
gift help us reach fifteen thousand
dollars by the end of the year using the
link below